hoarding this. Just remember all these recordings are up on the member site for you to watch. The
last six or seven years of recordings are up on there to watch. So if you asked a question
and you weren't able to get on, you can always listen to the recording. It should be up tonight.
All right, so remember Cheekswabs are now available again. You can see on the member site,
the homepage. Well, as the Cheekswam page was the testing page that you could do Cheekswabs and
you can pay for them right on the site too. If you don't have Cheekswabs, you can order
right off of there too and fill out the Cheekswam form all self explained in there. So look at the
expanded protocols on our site. And please discontinue emailing questions. If you email questions,
they're probably not going to get on here. It's so please send to the questions on that bottom
blue box where it says questions. Remember that all our full members have access to all our
courses, so take advantage of that as well. And remember our blog is now only on our member site.
Our blog is not on our main site anymore. So for those who haven't been connected to us lately,
we have had the onslaught of a lawsuit from the Minnesota Medical Board and the FDA coming down
on us with our store and putting in any information on Fendezal or any claims in any of our long posts
for that this can be good for cancer care. Even the posts that I had which you can see them,
they're still all live on our member site. But even the posts where I had cited the studies where
curcumin was valuable for this, this, this, this, this, the FDA still made us take those posts down.
That's why we don't have the posts on the public site anymore. So if you're not a full member,
everybody here listed it is, but if someone is not a full member, they can't see that anymore.
If that is a tyranny, I don't know what you'll call it. I don't know what to call it. You can't
have any free speech. We're literally citing, citing studies that were done peer reviewed studies.
Unbelievable. Just absolutely insane. So the lawsuit with the Minnesota Board is being dismissed,
which prays God for that, but the FDA, they can do anything they want. So we cannot put any
information at Fendezal. We had to take all our posts down. They're all back up just on the members
only site. We had to take Fendezal off our store. We can still sell it. We just can't advertise it.
So if you need to buy Fendezal, just call us. We have to put in the order manually. It's unbelievable.
So make sure you look at the, you can still use the search bar. That's what I was talking about here.
On our member site for any of our posts, all our blogs, 900 blog posts are all on the member site for your
literary enjoyment. Questions now that came in. Just got my vitamin T, D test back and it was 55.8.
I'm taking three vitamin 80K complete or 80K avail. Do I need to increase my dose?
So 55.8, I wouldn't consider that low. That's, I would not add any more vitamin D if this was me.
But it does seem odd that how can my vitamin D is only 55.8 and I'm taking three of these a day.
I think that that's 15,000 I use a day. That's insane. Well, that does point to the possibility
that I didn't look at this person's genetics to review that, but the the 80R gene defect,
the VDR gene defect, vitamin D receptor gene defect. If you have that defect in your genes that can
decrease the availability of vitamin D to be absorbed, that is a big possibility.
Good items, normally vitamin D. Now, people can have vitamin D deficiencies that
confirm other reasons too. If they had their gallbladder removed, they don't absorb their fat very well.
They don't break down fat very well. Vitamin A, D and K and E are all fat soluble vitamins.
That means you don't break down those nutrients very well. You don't absorb those very well. So
there's other reasons why a person could have low vitamin D, even if they're their consuming
vitamin D supplementations. They can have very damaged gut. There's other reasons why you might
absorb the vitamin D, but those are some possibilities. But even all that said, 55.8 would not be in
my book considered low. Yeah, we'd really like to have cancer patients be 50 to 150. In that range,
I guess that would be considered a little low. But I wouldn't change anything based upon that 55.8
can be just fine. Second part of the question. If I was to stop taking facilitex. So facilitex is a drug
given for ERPR positive cancers. It is a selective estrogen receptor disruptor
classification of drugs. So it helps get rid of bad estrogens, you could say.
That's the purpose of taking that drug in most women that have a breast cancer that's either ER or
and or PR and or P her to positive that may be recommended for them to take. This person's asking if
I stop taking this drug, would I do a cheek swab to see which supplements that would be most appropriate?
Yes. Doing a cheek swab would be most appropriate. I have ERPR positive her to negative right now.
I'm taking clear dims. So clear dim is a dim product that helps pull out bad estrogens. I have
astral clear on head. Astral clear is a lignin product that helps pull out bad estrogens.
Is there something I could start before stop taking that? I would say before you stop taking that,
I can't tell you to stop taking that or start taking a drug. But if you're going to make that decision
and get another cheek swab test, we have several other good products that could help
with this issue. Now facilitex is a little bit different class of drugs. It helps
bad estrogens off the estrogen receptor. The only thing from a nutraceutical standpoint that will
help dislodge bad estrogens from the estrogen receptor is fermented soey. Not just soey. It's
got to be fermented soey. The only product that fermented soey out there right now,
allergy research used to have a fermented soey chewable. They discontinued that.
The only fermented soey product out there right now is the Hyland product. So Hyland is the name
of the product. It's called or Halen 951. That's the name of the product. I think that's how I
think that's how you smell it. Maybe it's 8 and no, it doesn't look right. I think that's how you
smell it. But I will test you for that if you do a cheek swab. That is the dosage of that is what we
really want to check if we're going to use that. If you called Hyland and you asked them about
the dosage and told them you have cancer, they say drink a whole bottle. It's a little 8-ounce bottle.
Drink a whole bottle a day. Well, these are, you know, this product is like $50 some dollars a
bottle. We have found sort of testing that people don't need a whole bottle. They can take one or two
or three or four or five tablespoons. As in the bottle, last them, you know, a week or three days. It's
a little bit less expensive. It's not wasted. My oncologist is not suggesting chemo at this time.
But he wants me, wants to put me on the following to stop the growth of breast cancer.
His colleague is the CDK46 inhibitor pill. It blocks the growth of signal cells.
It in the cancer cells and stops and tells them to stop going into growth cycle. So, this is a medication.
Phospholidex is, this is what we just talked about. It's a monthly injectable that blocks the
estrogen receptor. So, we just talked about the last question. My cancer cells have a high
expression of estrogen receptor. This drug will block that by kicking the estrogen off the receptor.
And we just talked about the only other thing that does that is the Highland 951 that
are embedded. So, any comments of this approach? Well, I can't legally tell you to take or not
to take a medication, even a group Zoom call like this. So, I can't really tell you what to do with that.
I'm not familiar with this drug here really at all. So,
I would have to look up some studies just like you would on that drug right there. This drug
obviously has all the negative side effects of blocky estrogens that no women like to experience.
And many women will start out something like that and go, I want to get off of it just like this
person and this question. I want to stop taking it. Usually they're having side effects.
You know, decreasing estrogen and then and all the symptoms that go along with that they want to do
a natural approach to do that instead of using a medication. Those are really the biggest comments
you see any issue with continuing to take Highland at estro clear. You can even if you decide to go on
in Basiladex, you can still take these nutrients. So, Highland I-51 is a complete food-based product.
So, there's no interactions with Highland whatsoever. Estro clear is a lignit. There's no interactions
with that whatsoever either. So, I also plan to continue detoxing and taking antioxidants to
seeding issues with this. The only thing that I don't know what that kiss quality is,
if it's an oxidizing agent or not, if it is an oxidizing agent, then you just have to consider
that if you're taking high dose antioxidants, you could be negating the effect of an oxidizing agent.
If this is what that is, what that is, I don't think so, but you'd have to Google that if I know.
Are you familiar with mistletoe IV therapy? Yes, very familiar with that. So, I have a provider here
that does that. So, mistletoe IV therapy is typically giving, you could give mistletoe IV or
mistletoe injections into your belly. The benefit of mistletoe injections is you can do it from home.
The benefit for mistletoe IV, you're getting much higher dose mistletoe. It's stimulated in immune
reactions, what really what it is. So, some people have very good results from that. So,
is there downsides to it? I don't really think so. I mean, I know people that have reacted
negatively to it, but you'll know that. It's going to hurt you long term, but they just had to stop
taking it. So, but there are other than that. No. Also, does Benagene lower sugar about other things?
Benagene, I don't think that Benagene is going, is that going to be a strong
glucose inhibitor in the bloodstream? So, if you did, let's say, a carburetor test,
your glucose was, I don't know, let's say, you know, 87, as you took some Benagene, is it going
to decrease your glucose? I don't believe so. I didn't see anything on it lowering blood glucose.
So, it pushes the crem cycle as really what it does. So, it decreases, the reason why Benagene
can be beneficial for cancer is that cancers that are driven through the Warburg effect, which is,
so glucose breaks down through glycolysis. You remember high school biology. And then you end up with
producing lactic acid. And lactic acid can be a fuel for cancer if the cancer is very
hungry and can't wait for the acetyl coincide to go into the crem cycle. And Benagene helps push
that function into the crem cycle so that you don't end up feeding cancer through glycolysis as
easily. So, there is a huge benefit to Benagene. I just interviewed one of the founders of
terobiologicals in a cutters clinic live podcast. I don't think Dustin had, has published that
live yet, but he can't even talk about cancer. The Benagene actually, the first studies with Benagene was on
oxal, because Benagene is oxaloacetate, which is one of the components of the crem cycle.
Some of the first studies on oxaloacetate and Benagene was using them with astrocytomas because it
could block the astrocytomas, feeding off of glutamate. So, long story short, they had to pull the FDA
made them pull that study, even though they had published studies showing that that would be beneficial,
made them pull everything off of their website that showed that Benagene and oxaloacetate
was beneficial for cancer. So, now they don't have anything up there on that. They're actually,
in a, they're starting to study actually in February at Mayo Clinic on oxaloacetate and
glioblastoma, I believe, which is brain cancer. And so, that's going to be exciting. It probably
will take a couple of years to get published. They did another study on oxaloacetate and
breast cancer, which have to use higher dose oxaloacetate. So, Benagene is the lower dose
of oxaloacetate. And then the company has an oxaloacetate CFS because they did multiple studies
on oxaloacetate and chronic fatigue syndrome. And that's the only thing they can publish on their
website right now. Is 250 milligrams dose a day a good daily dose? Yes, that's a good daily dose of
that. The oxaloacetate CFS is even a higher dose of that. So, that's the benefit of that.
It's giving it a higher dose in perpill soon. I'm experiencing sharp,
stabbing pains through my body, chest pains that go into my arms. I am very sensitive to being
touched. Everything hurts. What can I do? General practitioner prescribed a muscle relaxer,
steroid, oxycautin. None of these have helped. I take tumoric twice a day, but nothing seems
to stop the pain. So, sharp stabbing pains through your body, chest pain that goes into your
arms. Very sensitive to being touched. You always have to ask the question, where is that coming from?
Why is that? That's the question you want to ask. If you have not done a cheek swab
asking about this specifically, please do a cheek swab asking about this specifically
because I would, you know, that would help get to the bottom of that. Let me see, who was it that
asked these questions here? No, this person has not done a cheek swab real recently. We should do
another one to get to the bottom of that. So, what could be causing this? Could cancer be causing
this sharp stabbing pains through the body? Well, it depends on where the cancer is. Of course,
brain cancer, absolutely. So, if you have stabbing pains through your whole body, you have to think of
it has to be what's called an upper motor neuron lesion. Lesion just means it injury, okay? So,
there's something going on with an upper motor neuron. What's that mean? That means the brain
and the spinal cord. So, if you have metastasis to the spine, there could be pressure on the spinal
cord, and then you could have pains anywhere from that point down. So, if I have, let's say, metastasis
to my T12, my 12th erasic vertebrae, and it's putting pressure on my spinal cord, I wouldn't get
stabbing pains in my arms. I could get pains if it's affecting what are called afferent fibers
that are coming back to the brain. If that's what the pressure on the cancer in the spinal cord is
pushing on, I could have symptoms that are that are subjective, meaning pain, numbness,
tingling, hot cold sensations, things like that, but it'd be south of that lesion. It'd be below that
lesion. So, it could be, it's T12, it could be in my stomach, it could be in my legs, et cetera,
but I wouldn't be having shoulder pain, I wouldn't be having arm pain. So, upper motor neuron lesions
in the spinal cord, and in the brain. So, if I'm having it literally all over my body, you got to start
thinking, where else could I, you know, what else could be putting pressure on this nerve?
Well, a person could have no, no sign of cancer, no history of cancer, and they could have
these type of symptoms. Well, then you start going to what's causing inflammation in the brain.
So, it doesn't just space out compared lesion like a cancer, it could be something that's causing
inflammation in the brain. So, perfect example is post-concussive central person had a concussion,
multiple concussions years ago and now they're experiencing these weird pain symptoms all over their
body. Another example would be a live disease that affected the brain. Another example would be
effects of vaccination. So, were you vaccinated? These adjuvokes and vaccinations
randomly cross the blood brain, bury cause inflammation of the brain, cause damage,
microglial cells in the brain, wrapped up inflammation, you could experience these weird symptoms
throughout your whole body. What will help these things? Well, Tumeric is a good choice here.
This is very good. Tumeric, curcumin, but twice daily taking Tumeric. I mean, you want to decrease
inflammation that's going on in upper motor, in the spinal cord or in the brain. You have to take
fairly high doses. We're talking at least four grams of this a day. Many people will say,
eight grams, that you have to add other flavonoids to this. We've spoken a lot about flavonoids.
I won't type them out. Resveratrol, green tea extract, EGC, Corsatin,
white willow, bark, Boswellia. These are the flavonoids that are been proven to decrease inflammation
in the brain in the spinal cord. But you have to take high doses of it and you have to spread it
throughout the day because all these flavonoids have a very short half-life in your body. We need to
dissipate and are gone quite quickly. So if you have like Tumeric clear or you have curcuclear,
you need to be taken like maybe one an hour to get ahead of this and knock this down.
If a muscle relaxer did it help and if a steroid did it help and if oxycut did it help,
that even points more towards brain inflammation and microglial primate because all the studies that
were funded through billions of dollars into the post-coccus of study that have been done with
inflammation in the brain and microglial primate brain damage. In fact, I have several videos on
this that you can watch in the courses and I know they're in blog posts. They followed that these
drugs don't really work very well. What worked is the flavonoids. So high dose flavonoids, long
didn't answer to that. Sorry. Working on scans next month and waiting prodovo scan to confirm they
can do most of what PET scan could do. Yes, that would be my confirmation they could do most of what
PET scan to do. I've said that on prodovo scan is like if the an MRI at a CT scan and a PET scan
got married and had baby had a baby you'd have a prodovo scan. If not, what could I take if I need to
radiation x-rays in the future? You could do our radiation holiopad. So that's right on our store
site, our radiation holiopad. At what point do you recommend getting a replacement ion pro wave?
So your ion pro waves last about 80 to 100 sessions. There's instructions in your manual,
if you're a provider, how to clean it. There's also instructions on the video on how to clean your
ion pro wave in the right section of the member site. There's also instructions on how to clean it
and how long they last in the frequency healing course that you all have access to.
So if you'd like, oh gosh, I've used this at least 80 times, then order a new one. It's really
cheaper for you to order it right from true rife because we don't get a discount. We have to get it
from true rife. We have to pay shipping and then we have to pay shipping to you. It's just order it
directly from true rife. Are there any rife products you recommend that will go higher frequencies,
those currently only possible via F122 bulb setting without doing a foot bath. No, in order to do the
higher 30, 40,000 hurts settings. You have to use the foot bath and that's what's in the foot bath
programs. Are you able to name any done profit organizations dedicated to researching alternative
cancer treatments? I don't know. I don't know of any. I wish I did and it's probably because I haven't
looked so might be a good idea. So if you guys come up with anything, let me know.
If a appropriate question, are you willing to discuss treatment of your own cancer after
it's spread to the colon? Did you have an operation to remove it? Or does all it be a treatment protocol
and what was your thought process? So I did discover my cancer and tell it was metastasized
to my colon. Did I have an operation? No. There is an operative procedure for my type of cancer,
but it is holding rotusk and it does not work. So that was out of the question. There is a chemotherapy
procedure for my type of cancer, but it was by their own admission horrible statistics. So it was
really easy for me to say forget that. So no, I didn't do any medical care and I do any standards
of care. Now again, that doesn't mean I'm against standards of care. My cancer showed great results
with chemotherapy. I would have at least considered it. I did not consider it because it just
statistically was not a viable option. So I did the rif and did my nutritional protocol was,
I did black sand blood road, I did all the mute, I did multiple different supplements.
I stayed away from eating a lot of red meat. I didn't eat dairy products and so that was my
protocol. I talk about it in multiple different areas. I do oncologists want to use targeted
hormones for my bilateral ER positive invasive ductile breast cancer and give you lupron.
Of course, that's it. Rival cycleib
to shrink by two words and give me more surgical options. Still double messed up to me. Maybe less
radical reconstruction. He said that the drugs would be temporary. What are the risks? Well,
again, I'm not a pharmacologist. I'm not an MD. I can't call it other risks of those drugs,
but I do highly suggest you Google them. Just Google them. You can see the risks of these
drugs. You can see the side effects of these drugs. That's something you're going to have to do your
own work on. I literally, that's not my specialty. I legally can't make too many comments on that.
But you, it's all over the internet. You can easily Google each one of those drugs.
See what the negative side effects are and look at the risk reward. Just like I did with my cancer,
I just looked at the risk reward. Interested with my cancer, a study had, when I found out I had
cancer about two years prior to when I found out about seven years ago, Mayo had just finished a
study. I think on 10 patients that had that had my cancer. They did this drug and it was a
repurposed old chemo therapy. I can't remember the name of it. They call this their trial
this huge success because one person lived like 16 months. I thought, okay, one person lived 16 months.
On top of that, you read the report, read the entire report, which was very long. The one person
lived 16 months, he went into remission with the chemo therapy and then his cancer came back and I
take 14 months and he refused further chemo therapy, which again told me, okay, that means,
okay, the chemo therapy sent him into remission. Why would he refuse it if it came back?
Except that it probably caused so many side effects for him. He was like, it was a guy. He's probably like,
forget it. I ain't doing that again. I'd rather die. Okay, well, it told me a lot. The guy went into
remission with it and he refused it. That was their success story. Okay, easy decision for me,
like the, what are those capital one commercials? Easiest decision of the decision making
decisions. Well, I'm not going down that route. But again, I was willing. Again, I come from a
perspective of, okay, if I gave myself to Jesus Christ, I have to go, okay, Lord, if you want, but if
you want me to still do this, Lord, because you have a purpose in this cancer that's way beyond me
getting better, then I'm willing. I'm willing to do the chemo if it's you need to witness to some
chemo nurse or something like that. But please, you know, my heart, I do not want to do it even if it
had good stats, you're going to have to change my heart. But I trust that God could change my heart.
He's big enough to be able to change my heart if I, you know, open to listening to him. Well, he
didn't give me any inclination that I wanted to do the chemo. And so it just was just a done deal
with me. I was just done. And so it was either I was going to, you know, figure out myself by God,
give me wisdom to help my body heal, or I was going to go home and I was okay with either outcome. So
it's, you know, so far, I'm still here. So I'll just go, hey, day by day, I don't know if the
cancer's going to come back and I'm going to be dead in a month or I will get run over by a
dump truck tomorrow. So you just continue to live your life daily like you're going to get run over
by a dump truck tomorrow. So that you, you are in a deep enough self analysis to that you can be asking
God what you're supposed to be doing today. What are your thoughts about this combo? Again, I cannot
comment on the combo of medications. These are questions I just, I don't have experience on. I just
can't comment on them. I don't want to do you people a disservice. I don't want you to, you guys
to think that I know everything about, you know, these medications and their interaction. I mean,
you can look up each medication. You can see the side effects of it, but it's just going to be
hard-pressed and find any information on interactions between these medications. So you're going to have
to have a relationship with your heavenly father that you can ask him and ask him to give you wisdom
whether you should do these things. Should I do a double best activation? I do
reconstruction. Nobody can answer that question. The truth is we've had breast cancer patients come
to us. They were like, forget it. I've done with them. I'm not doing any more standards of care
and they are still alive today. But we've also had breast cancer patients that took that stance. I've
done with them, but they've passed away, but they were at peace about their physician. Then we've
had breast cancer patients that went the whole medical route and that passed away. And we had
breast cancer patients that went the whole medical route also and they're still with us. So you can't
take a dogmatic position. And I think any doctor that's going to say, you do what I do. This is what
you have to do. This is what's going to save your life. It's like, really? Okay. Yeah, because honestly,
if things go south, what's that doctor going to do? We do the best we do the best. They're not
taking responsibility for this. This responsibility has to fall on your shoulders. You have to decide
what's going to be best for you. That's just the honest truth. So he said the drugs would be
temporary. And what are the risks? I don't know. What are your thoughts of the combo? Should you
still be doing some natural aromatase inhibitors? Yes. I would to say like that question we had
earlier, even if you're going to go with the medical route, I would still be doing natural aromatase
inhibitors along with it. He said, I'm an imminent danger of the large four centimeter tumor breaking
the skin. And I'm worried about this. No one to help me with this locally. I especially do not want to
have an emergency surgery decision. I agree. And you don't want to want to be in a situation that
you're making an emergency decision. And you know, a lot of people aren't comfortable with the tumor
breaking through the skin. And I get that. And that's where doing some other intervention can be
beneficial. You know, I tell everybody that's thinking about doing chemotherapy is scared to death of
it, but they feel like they're being kind of led in that direction. Is that the truth is you can
start. It doesn't mean you have to, you know, if they say, oh, we're going to do 12 weeks of this,
then 12 weeks of it doesn't mean you can do it all. You're in control of your body. You can stop
if this eye I'm done. You know, you might change your mind. I mean, people, we're going to start this.
I really feel led to do chemotherapy. They do two rounds and they're like, I'm stopping. That's it.
And it knocked it down. So just remember that too. He said, my ultrasound showing the tumors
near the same size since September doesn't matter. Interesting logic there. It is opinion. The alternative
program isn't working. I would, I think it's kind of funny, you know, some of the dogmatic positions
of the doctors, if you were doing his program and there was the same side since September, he'd say,
good, we put a break, the breaks on it, which would probably be true. And it's just kind of funny.
So good thing when I would recommend if you're getting these kind of silly dogmatic
nonsensical answers like this is to get maybe another oncologist's advice too. You go to four,
five, six oncologists, you know, and have somebody that you feel the most comfortable with it.
Ultimately, that's what you want to do. You want to feel really comfortable with it.
I want to give the oncologist another plan or compromise that we can work together. I want to be
comfortable and I don't want to make an uninformed decision. Totally agree with you and there's
nothing wrong with talking to more doctors. The different person, I had a second opinion
appointment today with the head neck surgeon for my HP, HPV positive squamous cell cancer on my
tonsil. He also said that surgery was not an option. And he would immediately put it a feeding
tube because I am malnourished. I've lost almost 40 pounds. Well, you don't want to be in a state of
caquexia. So a feeding tube can have its benefits to get food in you so that you're not continuing to
lose weight. And a feeding tube is not, it will not be permanent. My new oncologist mentioned the
mutal therapy working for this cancer. But that was before today's news and I don't know what he'll
say about the surgeon's evaluation. So a mutal therapy is completely different than surgery.
Mutal therapy is a drug IV drip that remember has blocks the pre-for receptor on the T cell so that
it will help stimulate immune response against the cancer. So if the surgeon said surgery is not
an option, I don't think that has anything to do with the mutal therapy being an option or not.
So the mutal therapy is an option that might be a good option to take.
I know they use a lot of sugar and feeding tubes. Well, no, feeding tubes you are putting your food
in your feeding tube. You don't have to use their prepared stuff. Cake farms uses a prepared food
for feeding tubes. You can get it from there. People have made their own peg food feeding
food with like grains first and protein powders and different things like that. You can make that
yourself. And I'm out of fact, I think we have a recipe on the blog post. If you look for a peg food
feeding tube recipes, we have one of our blog posts. You can make your own stuff.
If I could choose the chemo drugs, are there any better than others to request? Again,
I'm not a specialist in chemo drugs. You'd have to refer to what your oncologist is recommending.
And if a mutal therapy is something that they say works for you, you have to have a certain
gene type to be able to use the mutal therapy. They would test you for that. That might be your
better option. Is there anything else I could be asking about treatment options to mitigate the side
effects or damage to your body if you're I'm assuming using a mutal therapy. You have to treat the
side effects as they come with the mutal therapy because the mutal therapy will decrease
your T cells response to all your cells. And you can end up with different inflammatory
states, most probably like colitis and things you have to treat it as they come up. What should I
ask in my next cheek swab about the right update? You can ask, you can just put your questions when
you have things like this, put all those questions that you have in your cheek swab requests form so
that we can get to the bottom of this as best we can do. You got to understand I can only do so much.
I don't know everything. I'm not your healer. God is your healer. My role is to guide you in nutrition
and in frequency use. And I can't tell you medical answers. All right, let's get to some of your
chat questions. My daughter is losing hair. Doctor said it was from COVID. He told us to use
L methyl folate. We also made the hair remedy you mentioned on your site, lavender rosemary, etc.
My head started itching and so are two more of my kids. I assume that your head started itching
from the lavender rosemary. You need lady to water it down a little bit more with a
carrier oil if that's true. The loss of hair also, I don't think methyl tetrahedral folate is
really going to be the cure for loss of hair. The other thing you want to look at is how it may have
affected her thyroid. So if there's a decrease in thyroid T3, T4 production, then you could end up
with hair loss. And that's one of the symptoms of low thyroid. And then if you do a thyroid test,
you want to make sure that you are requesting from your doctor a complete thyroid profile. Because
many times they'll just do a TSH test. And many times they'll do a TSH, a T3, and a T4 that's still
that adequate. You need to get three T3, three T4 and reverse T3. Because many times T3 is made
and then it's a flip cis isomer of T3, which can never flip back to the usable T3. So your
thyroid makes T3 and T4. T3 is the active form of the hormone, but 94, 95 percent of thyroid hormone
is released as T4. And then it's turned into T3 in the gut and in the liver. So it can be turned
into reverse T3. And then a person can have normal TSH and slightly low T3, slightly low T4 and really
elevated reverse T3. And that's really their problem. And then you also want to look and make sure
that the person doesn't have Hashimoto's and you test for TPO antibodies. So that is a more
complete a thyroid panel that you'll want to ask for. So you want to write that down. So that's
what you're asking for. You want to measure her thyroid. You want to get to the reason why, right?
What do you think about deuterium related to illness and disease and can deuterium depletion help
us? Wow. Good question. So deuterium is oxygen with an extra hydrogen on it and deuterium is in
all of our water supplies. A percentage of our water is deuterium. They're really interesting
studies on deuterium. Societies, or you could say cultures that drink water that has less deuterium
in it live longer across the board. They live longer. Well, why is that? Deuterium is heavy water,
it's called heavy water. And it doesn't function in our body as water. And it can block water's
function in our body. So you can actually buy deuterium depleted water. So where are the societies that
drink water? Where is water that has less deuterium in it? Every all of our water throughout this
entire planet has deuterium in it. But there's some water that has less deuterium in it. And that is
water that's melted from glacial, it's glacial water. There is a bottled water company called Icelandic.
You've heard of Icelandic water. They might sell it in the grocery store. They might sell it in
an agastation. Comes in a kind of a square model with ridges on it. It is naturally deuterium
depleted water. It has a lower content of deuterium in it. And really that there can be benefits to
drinking Icelandic water. So deuterium depleted water, you could actually buy. There's a process where
you can deplete deuterium in the water. It's just quite expensive. And there's been studies where
people have used deuterium depleted water with cancer. And some that people had gotten better just
using deuterium depleted water. It can be difficult to get. You have to order it. I think from overseas,
I don't think there's a place in the US that makes it. But it's, but you can get slightly deuterium
depleted water with Icelandic water. That's one thing I did talk about what you do with your
cancer. We're about a month I drank Icelandic water. And then we had it on order. You could order it
on Amazon. We added just on a delivery. So probably a couple of months that we were drinking Icelandic,
which is slightly deuterium depleted water. I don't remember the numbers of the scale. I'd have to
look that up. But there can be benefits to deuterium depleted water sources.
There are small bumps on her head back to her daughter with hair loss around three total. One of my
kids mentioned she has one on her head to the same child mentioned a bruise feeling. How can we tell
if it's COVID or something worse? My poor daughter lost about half of her hair and losing it most on
top of her head near the back. Can't show pictures. You can email me some those pictures
and that would be best. Just email them to me. Would a fast, be a good idea to help with hair loss
or whatever this is. I would say no. We could do a cheek swab to test that. We should do a cheek swab
on your daughter, for sure, but send me the pictures. Email me the pictures.
In my diet guide made for me, there was no mention of bread other than grains. I know wheat is out
and must be gluten-free. Is it okay for bread with different ingredients? Well, you have to
do a little bit of research on what gluten-free is. So if you're supposed to be on a gluten-free diet,
the continuation of the question, my genetic test is there any way to get back
quicker for extra cost or do they just take a long time? I'm scheduled to get back mid-march.
Really, we like to know what my genetics are. We can't. It doesn't, you know, they put it in the
system. There's no way even with that pain extra. You can't do that. So we've asked about that
in the past. But if you're supposed to be on a gluten-free diet, then you have to understand
what gluten-free is and there's a lot of different gluten-free options out there for bread and
different different companies that are making some fairly good gluten-free bread now, too. But you
want to do some research on what gluten-free is. You are so crazy. I think you spelled
crazy. You think you spelled smart or wrong there. Thank you. With pressure to get
two COVID shots in 221, what is available supplement to powder spike proteins as I feel these have
progressed my cancer? Yeah, I've been careful not to get too much COVID vaccines because we have
a number of people that have gotten COVID vaccines. I think this is my opinion. I think there's
a horrible mistake. COVID vaccines are not vaccines whatsoever. They're mRNA
tools to damage your body period. You don't have to be a conspiracy theorist to see what has
taken place in our society with us. Huge spike in cancer and cardiac issues. And if you are
denial of that, you're a denial of reality. So I'm glad you're open to this. But some of the things
that you could do to help a person is, first of all, for the clot formation, I highly recommended
product called lumbrosine. These two products here are both US enzymes products. Nanozyme
is the other one. So lumbrosine and Nanozyme are two good products that are enzymes that will help
break down the clot formation that could take place that could cause cardiac issues. Another good
product is ala scented. I think that's how you spell it. That's a premier research garlic. But you
can get garlic. You're really anywhere. You can get garlic on with a counter, which is good. Don't
buy any other lumbro kinase product because that's what lumbrosine is. It's lumbro kinase.
Don't buy any other nano kinase product except these US enzymes products. These are the absolute
cleanest purest lumbro kinase and nano kinase. Literally nothing else touches it. This is PRL's garlic
which is a blood thinner. So if you're out of blood thinner, you have to be careful of that.
Take it too much of this. But really any garlic, any over the counter garlic, even that garlic
brand is a good product. They're still good products. This is going to help with this won't help with
the spike proteins, but this will help with the effects of the spike proteins on the red blood cells
and the anothelial cells that is causing the clot formation. As far as getting rid of the spike
proteins themselves, there's nothing that's been proven to do that. However, looking at
keylating agents, like the Vandolex Citergy is a good product that we have. It's one of my favorite
products as far as a keylating agent in such so that we privately labeled it as our phase zero, oops,
phase zero assist. This is just got some really, it's got such a nice blend of keylators
that you think of what that's what you want to do is try to grab on to the spike proteins and pull
them out of our body. So that's what I would use is this. You know, if you're using Pectisol C,
that can be beneficial. We have key look clear. That's beneficial. The Vandolex Citergy is just
got a bigger blend of keylators in it. Make sure that you're not constipated. Doing coffee
animals are nothing but helpful. And a reason why coffee animals are so helpful is because they help
stimulate your parasympathetics. That is going to help you get rid of this stuff. Parasympathetic
nervous system is your neurological control over your immune system and the neurological control
over your detoxification pathways. So these are the kind of things that I would suggest. If I had
the vaccine, I would be probably taking two of these and about three times per day. So in the same
thing with the nanos, I'm in the same thing with the garlic and the same thing with the Vandolex Citergy
really have to flood your body with that. The itchy and was the beginning of our experience
in the same thing. Thank you so much for what you do. Let's get cheek swabs on that.
Hydrogen isotope gets plugged in the place normal. Hydrogen, yeah. So that's deuterium,
double theatomic weight. So it's called heavy water. So this is back to the deuterium question.
It's called heavy water. Hydrogenic diaphyl depletes deuterium. That's interesting because I am not
read that. I'm not seeing anything of that. I listened to, I actually had a seminar once listening to
the president of the company who created the deuterium depletion technology. I think he's from
Sweden. I don't know. I think it's from Europe. I don't think it was from the United States.
Really, really interesting stuff though. So you can actually make your own deuterium depleted water
by taking your water, freezing it, and then I forgot the whole thing. You could get slightly lower
deuterium levels in your water by freezing it and then pouring off the water that's not quite
frozen because deuterium depleted water will freeze at a lower freezing point and you keep
doing that over and over till it just would be really a pain to do. So can you remind me and put my
mind at ease a little hopefully when I'm not having any unusual pain but my markers are still
up to the 600s. What could this possibly mean given all the protocols I've using thanks to the
events? So are you talking about your two markers? Your CA 1999 marker. I'm not sure what you're
speaking about and you do want to with any blood test like two markers, you want to compare that
with your other tests, your CT scans, what you're on college is to say and see where you're at. So
sometimes two markers are stubborn and don't drop very quickly. So just guide that with your
subjective findings and other objective findings you don't ever want to just use one test.
I asked the question about three estrogen blockers. If I decide to do that and a college has said
they are stronger than Tamoxin, is there a point to taking other natural ones too?
Well, you know, I said no, I mean, yeah, maybe not. Maybe you could put a pause on the natural things.
If you're going to do those things, it's going to really shut down all your estrogens.
The only one that I would suggest that you would do along with it if you're going to do those is maybe
the highland because the highland is not an estrogen depletor. The highland dislodges the estrogen
from the estrogen beta receptors and that is key. So to stimulate it because those are the
estrogen beta receptors are apoptonic receptors. So that's the whole idea of estrogen positive and
progesterone positive and her too positive cancers is that estrogen is blocking the apoptonic
receptors. So using highland can help break that up. So highland doesn't necessarily pull estrogen out
of your body like DM and you know, I see three and and the ligaments and things like that. But it helps
dislodge kind of like that fermented so is kind of like a crowbar that gets into the receptor and
cranks out the bad estrogen and gets it out of that receptor. So that's I would still maybe consider
doing that. The foot detox bath, how many times a week? The reason we don't specify because some people
don't do it at all, some people do it every day. So it really has to do with your time, how much time
do you have? So what's reasonable? Okay, I have all the time in the world. I'm retired. I don't have
anything else to do. And I don't mind doing it. I just sit there and watch TV. Well, then do it
every day. But some people are like, Oh my gosh, it's just another thing to do. And if I do that,
then I don't have time to do my son or I don't have to, if you're weighed between things like that,
then you do have to kind of make a decision. I'll be honest with you. I never did the foot bath.
I just never did it. It's like I just did not feel led to do that. And you know, some people really
feel led to do that. I think it's a great tool. But I'm just being honest with you guys. I didn't do
it. I'm just too 80, 80, 80, 80, I couldn't sit there for like foot in the bath. I can't go on
vacation with my wife because I'll sit down at the pool and probably say we're going to sit at the
pool and just get a relax. I can sit there five minutes without thinking, oh, goodness, six. I'm
going to get my book on tape and study. I got to go study and I got to go, you know, I can't do it.
I'm just too 80 HD. That's just the way God made me. I just got to, I just kids at there. That's
just me. So when I called the person on the Purdue vote to take a place on the PET scan or CT scan,
she did not seem like it would show like the PET scanner. They have to be careful what they say.
So just so you know that. If I get side effects from the estrogen blockers, do you have protocols for
that? Not really. Because the side effects that you're going to have from estrogen blockers are
because they're doing what they're supposed to do. We need that they are depleting all your
estrogens. And that's what your side effects are. So your side effects are, you know, you don't feel
very womanly. You're going to have, you know, drive agile track. You're going to, you know, just
not feel good. You're just, you know, there's going to be all these
hormonal changes in your body. And some women tolerate that well. It's the same thing with men going
on energy deprivation therapy for prostate cancer. Some men tolerate that pretty well because
they really need to have a whole lot of testosterone testosterone before they started. But some men that
had a lot of testosterone don't tolerate that well at all. And they just hate it. Absolutely hate
same thing with women with their estrogen levels. Even if you're gone through menopause and your
ovaries aren't producing very much estrogen at all. Even if you had your ovaries removed, your
adrenal glands are still producing estrogen. And when you deplete the rest of your estrogen,
there is an effect of it. And there really isn't anything that you could do. If, you know, other than
taking estrogen, which completely depletes defeats the whole purpose of going on estrogen blockers. So
you certainly wouldn't do that. So there really, really isn't anything that you can really do about
that. Except maybe some of the, maybe if you don't feel good, you can use creams, different things
like that. But my Dutch test a couple of years ago, did it show screaming high estrogen or bad pathways?
I'm wondering if they are going to help. Well, your Dutch test, if you did your Dutch test,
while you're on those medications, you would see severely depleted estrogen levels.
That's the thing. You could do a Dutch test. So Dutch test is a dried urine hormone test. You
could do a Dutch test with a woman who is ERPR positive. And they could have barely normal to low
16 hydroxyestero, which is their bad estrogen, quote, unquote, and fairly low for hydroxyestero,
which is your other bad estrogen. And then they're going, well, what the heck? Why do I have this
cancer then? Okay, remember, you don't have breast cancer because of bad estrogens. Bad estrogens
are not causing your breast cancer. Bad estrogens are just limiting apoptosis. So that bad estrogens
cause cancer. So the crazy insanity of somebody, you know, you know, getting estrogen depleted
drugs and then thinking that they're solving, that's the total solve of their breast cancer. That's
just not true. You're on colitis mate, lead you to believe that. But then come back with we need to
still do chemotherapy because chemotherapy can kill cancer. depleting to all your estrogen is
not going to kill cancer. But it can if you're doing other things like the rife and nutrition, it can
help get apoptosis starting. So the tumor can start shrinking because of the other things you're doing
not because of the estrogen depletion. So depleting estrogen is not going to kill the cancer
depleted estrogen will allow the cancer to die because of the other things you're doing. So
I hope that answers that question. Thanks so much. I will try to get all my questions early, but
I always think of everything. I understand. That's why we have the chat open on our
members side because lots of times we're talking about these things and that sparks questions in
your head. So that's really good. Luckily I found a functional doctor here that is familiar with
low-dose daltrexone. Good. I think we talked about that last week or the week before and are
an emissive and can prescribe. If you just want to take art emissited orally, you don't need a prescription
for that. We have art emissited in our store. Low-dose daltrexone is a drug and you need that compounded
and you need that prescribed. So that's great. Anything I do will keep you posted as a rife is my number one
I assume I need to be on the rife while a while before seeing results. Yeah, keep up the good work.
All right. Remember, if you have questions about your work called things, you can get your cheek swabs
in. Look on the member site for all the details on that. Also, please remember, do not email any
questions. They won't get answered at this point. We've been kind of harping on this for the last
four months. Make sure your questions get in through the member site or I just won't and just because
they just get buried and I don't see them. I literally get 150 emails a day. I'm not joking. So please
don't do that. Other people have asked about Ed and Ashley. They just are officially either one of
them are with us any longer. Ed is dealing with her son with acute myeloid leukemia AML.
Please, please be praying for him. He's in doing another chemo session. He waited yesterday for it.
So we're in contact with Ed. She's a good, very good friend who always will be a colleague and friend
of ours. She just can't work right now. So she's a permanent leave. I don't know if she'll be
coming back. Ashley is a wonderful mom to her little baby and she just said, oh my gosh, she's so
sick and cute. So please be praying for her change of life. So please don't email their emails anymore.
I Ashley's email is get it shut down and Ed's email will be shut down by next week too. So just don't
you get a bounce back probably. All right, love you all. I'll be praying for you all. I thank you
for continuing to pray for us. We cherish your prayers. If you have to send reports to labs at
cuttersclidic. Good question and labs. L-A-B-S at cuttersclidic.coinityrsclidic.com.
All right, thank you much. Bye bye now.